from catholic priest to prisoner thomas
muhosha is led away after being
convicted for the murder of macdonald
masambuka a man with albinism
five others were handed life sentences
including a medical officer a policeman
and the victim's brother
i'm happy he has been sentenced to life
imprisonment so that i don't have to see
him again
just like i will never see his brother
whom he betrayed
the group was found guilty of luring
masambuka into a trap with a promise of
marriage but they killed him to traffic
the 22 year old's organs
some believe albino parts bring wealth
and good luck in superstitious rituals
his murder is one of dozens against
albinos in malawi in the past decade i
think this is a lesson to all malawians
that this
tendency killing with
of persons with albinism
should with immediate effective stuff
because we are also human beings
we need to enjoy the life as everyone
else
fear remains in parts of africa for
people born with albinism
activists say at least in this case the
powerful have been held to account
barbara anger al jazeera